welcome to the hero daily my name is
dimas this is an exciting day to be an
mcu fan and we have what seems to be um
the confirmation of patrick stewart
coming out in the trailer for dr
strange's multiverse of madness but see
he's not the only fox
universe character that is coming to the
mcu
it looks like we may have confirmation
on deadpool
coming
through the multiverse uh by means of
the uh poster that was released by
marvel
eagle-eyed fans are uh looking at the
poster pixel by pixel and it looks like
they found deadpool in a shard of glass
uh and i mean i have looked at it here
it is
i
see what they're talking about i am
excited if it is uh let me know what you
guys think do you guys think that this
is an actual possibility uh it's it's
sometimes a stretch what we
speculate because or we see what we want
to see but i personally think that it's
a strong possibility just because it
will be the best way to bring in a
deadpool himself by the means of a
multiverse obviously i mean the rumors
have been running wild and
the rumor of patrick stewart coming back
as uh charles xavier was one of those
wild rumors that i heard initially and
said well that's a bit of a stretch but
we ended up getting it so i wouldn't put
the possibility of deadpool coming out
in this movie even for a small moment or
maybe even an end credit scene uh past
the possibility you know what i mean so
do me a favor uh comment down below what
you guys think do you
want deadpool in this movie do you think
that maybe deadpool's humor
may
hinder this movie's overall
tone
or do you think that it may be a
necessary comic relief to see him pop up
randomly in one of the
multiple universes that doctor strange
is
seemingly crashing through uh in the the
trailer uh let me know down below uh
this is an exciting thing to talk about
because
the
possibilities have now just opened
way more because we got what i thought
was gonna be the big reveal of patrick
stewart himself and it ended up being in
the trailer which means that it is not
the big reveal
that we thought we were going to get
so there's something bigger out there
that's going to happen in the movie and
i'm so excited to see exactly what it is
uh so comment down below
like if you like this video
subscribe if you can and i'll see you
tomorrow